let's go next to our caller from the
five six three area code who is calling
today from five six three oh did you say
this is Earl bill bill hey Bill what's
up um I'm just concerned I uh yeah live
in Iowa
yeah one of our senators is senator
Grassley right and one of the only
defenses about the why the bill was good
for us with taxes included it's bad to
demonize the rich yeah didn't why would
that come out if that's not true because
more than 100 billionaires in the world
they unbalanced the whole thing yeah
this is a talking point it's not just
Grassley who has used that talking point
and I've actually seen you know this is
why it's great when you have groups like
patriotic millionaires and others come
out and say this isn't about demonizing
rich people this is just about
recognizing that they got rich in part
because of public infrastructure and
because of the labor of others and
because of the regulatory environment so
we just want people paying what's fair
and not unbalancing the economic system
in a way that's destructive it's not
there's no you know there was that
billionaire dude I played the clip from
CNBC a few months ago who was like
almost cry I think he was crying in the
segment about Elizabeth Warren's mean to
rich people it's not about individuals
it's just about we need a system that
balances out and that works and balances
out so it doesn't carry on like the
oligarch for life had to that's in its
breath yeah and these people look at
Trump spawn I mean these people are
gonna carry on billions of dollars of
influence yeah
with nothing behind them no doubt anyway
I just thought it's odd when they that's
their only defense I totally agree with
you and I'm hearing myself on a three
second delay on some kind of device so
I'm gonna let you go I really appreciate
the call and hope to hear from you again